Harry and Megan
the dreariest couple in the history of
planet Earth
famously abandoned their Royal duties
for a life of privacy they left the
Goldfish bowl of Great Britain for the
camouflage of California remember
famously sheltered from the evil British
press and since then they've kept an
incredibly low profile as they vowed to
if you excuse the massive book deals the
Silicon Valley startups the preaching
videos about well-being the podcast the
speeches and the major Network
interviews with everyone from Oprah
Winfrey to James Corden but it barely
been seen or heard at all have they well
on Thursday they'll quietly and
apologetically release their 100 million
dollar documentary series on Netflix
there are trailers for this and viewers
with sensitive stomachs should look away
now
[Music]
why did you want to make this
documentary
no one sees what's happening behind
closed doors
[Music]
utterly nauseating uh I mean literally I
literally recoiled while watching it
of sanctimony the fake drama the hammy
woe is me that's been going on now for
years the somber tickle of the piano
geezy staged black and white photographs
of this very ordinary young oppressed
couple
having what appears to be some tiny
semblance of fun in their California
Mansion as they count all their money
incredibly it gets worse
I had to do everything I could to
protect my family
oh
I mean nothing says protecting your
family like doing a reality TV findable
documentary about every aspect of your
family life for the delectation of the
entire planet does it Harry well the
brain pack of Paparazzi photographers
jostling the space to Hound the happy
couple that's what we just saw right
childhood photographs clearly intended
to evoke the tragic death of his mother
Diana
both photographers we just saw weren't
actually interested in Prince Harry at
all they were at the premiere of a Harry
Potter movie five years before Harry
even met Megan there were any Royals
there at all
there's apparently sneaky paparazzo
lurking above the substances was
actually invited there to cover their
meeting with Archbishop 2-2 in Cape Town
another photo used in the promotions
shows Harry's outstretched hand
apparently shielding the couple from
photographers only it's actually a
cropped photo of Harry with
ex-girlfriend Chelsea Davey taken in
2007 and a press Scrump shown dashing
after the unhappy couple was actually
chasing after reality TV stuff one of
their compatriots now Katie Price at
Crawley magistrates Court
ironically for a couple of repeatedly
sued newspapers for intrusion and
inaccuracy
they've just put a lot of Whoppers into
their trailers that's before we even get
to the main event
when the stakes were this high
doesn't it make more sense to hear our
story from us
oh shut up
what do you mean the stakes of this hire
Do You Think You Are
other than latte munching
imbecile living in luxury in California
while the rest of the world is a
constant living crisis moaning and
whining about an institution which gave
you the titles on which you now trade
millions of dollars
when you're talking about Stakes are
there other than the massive gigantic
stake you're currently plunging into our
monarchy over here
and as for telling their story sorry if
I missed something I thought you've been
telling your truth which is often a pack
of lies from the moment you abandon this
country
well today's new trailer doubles down on
the last trailer and there's more tears
remember that clip of Megan wants
showing us how she could cry like that
at the drop of a little tiny tarnished
Tiara remember that she could do it like
that
just bear that in mind when you watch it
did you get that one
shameful comparisons for Princess Diana
I remember Prince Harry being very very
angry about the media exploiting his
mother for commercial game yeah what has
he done with this Netflix series he's
used his mother to sell it
could there be a more grotesque
exploitation or a more hypocritical one
than him using his Dead Mother's imagery
to engender sympathy for himself again
as the great victim in this world
I find it all puke making
and I speak of someone who's actually in
one of these things I pop up
yeah me
um and to my astonishment I was being
very nice about Meghan Markle
let's have a listen
it's really hard to look back on it now
and go what on Earth happened
[Applause]
[Music]
everything changed there's a hierarchy
of the family you know there's leaking
but there's also planting of stories
there was a war against Megan to suit
other people's agendas it's about hatred
it's about race it's a dirty game
and suffering of women marrying into
this institution this feeling frenzy
I realized they're never going to
protect you
I was terrified I didn't want history to
repeat itself
[Music]
no one knows the full truth
we know the full truth
oh God you wouldn't know the truth if it
hit you around the back of your head
and Harry here's the point
we're not really interested in your
truth you've been saying it for the last
two three years your version of what you
think happened
and yeah I did say Megan was becoming a
royal rock star and I'm pleased you
quote me in there because it shows that
I was like the rest of the British media
very positive about your new bride until
your Mutual Behavior became hypocritical
and ridiculous after the wedding
you'll claim that you're the victims of
a dirty game is especially Brazen given
that these trailers have been released
to deliberately overshadow a visit by
The Prince and Princess of Wales United
States
the timing of course is Unforgettable
unforgivable if entirely unsurprising a
typically cynical ploy to overshadow a
vitally important Royal tool the first
sense of death of Queen Elizabeth what
about his father in all this a man who's
not even been coronated as king yet
still mourning the death of his mother
is he going to cop it in this series you
can bet your life you will Charles is
going to have to take it again from his
son with no ability to speak out and
return fire
this series will do great numbers for
Netflix
but maybe not for the reasons they hoped
the Oxford English Dictionary defines
hate watching as the activity of
watching for the sake of enjoyment
derived from mocking or criticizing
that's a measure of success Harry and
Megan you're going to have a Smash Hit
but of course the real much of success
of both of them will be the same as it
always has been how much damage can they
inflict on our royal family on our
monarchy how can they make it all about
them how can they continue to play the
victims when they live in such
unparalleled luxury the other side of
the world
this gruesome twosome only survived by
cashing in on what's left of their Royal
status now
I said it before I'll say it again
tonight King Charles has stripped them
all their remaining titles and cast them
out from any connection to the royal
family any of them trusts them as far as
I could throw them because without it
they're just whining Millennial windbags
with a permanent victim complex knowing
that victim mode is what makes them all
the money